I already feel healthier and happier
this is probably the worst day I
definitely learned a lot about how
important and good water it is for you
it's the first morning of the challenge
so let's not drink some water
[Music]
hello what's up what's happening my name
is Nadia everyone my name is Jake and I
drank about one of these every day it's
28 ounces one gallon but for the next
seven days I'm going to be swapping
water drinking habits I don't really
know exactly what it is she drinks daily
instead of water I'll drink coffee
earlier pretty much anything besides a
glass of water
all right this is my first cup of the
day right here okay it's my first
morning and I need to drink coffee so
that's what we're gonna do
I already feel healthier and happier
drinking coffee in the morning it seems
like could be a beneficial thing wakes
you up but it really wakes you up for
like a short amount of time and then I
think I feel more tired just throughout
the day and I feel like I have more
headaches I'm only about two-thirds done
with coffee this morning like that much
is left so I'm on glass number four
I have 12 glasses left it to go and I've
already gone to the bathroom twice I
already have a killer headache I think
it's from all the caffeine so early in
the morning with no hydration to kind of
balance it out then it'll be number
seven
seven yeah continues later it's the
morning I'm going to head out to work
and I want to pass my kitchen to find my
water bottle just sadly sitting there
never okay this morning myself a wider
bottom but then as the week went on I
noticed that I did have more energy like
work I have been running me more
consistently and it's been just like no
problem to push myself to do that I'm
about to go for a run I just got off
work and I am kind of feeling a little
bit like energetic I was lethargic
I was super just not motivated to do
anything obviously it's the end of the
second workday I'm heading home I've had
a lacroix coffee and one glass of water
and I'm so tired and norming up is tired
at the end of work but I am today he
it's dinnertime which means I get to
really hard open with one finger
yeah yeah you know oh here's another
thing that I noticed that the weather
here in LA has significantly gotten
warmer and just fine Oh God
Oh howdy guys warmer I have been
drinking water really consistently all
day today it is hot it's so hot out it's
sunny and beautiful and the sky isn't
blue it's so hot out so it's been really
easy for me to be drinking a gallon of
water I don't think my spitting went
down at all okay I think I just it I
think it just wasn't clean it's weird as
that sounds I'm like sweating and I
don't know how I'm sweating cuz I've had
no liquid in my body today so how am i
sweating it makes no sense to me are you
continuing to sweat hmm there's just
like so much this is great I hope that
Jake is doing all right this is probably
the worst day it's so hot I can't Los
Angeles is not the place to not drink
water
Friday morning I just took a shower and
I washed my face which you know that
always kind of makes me skin feel a
little dry but for some reason this
morning my skin just feels so dehydrated
my skin was a lot drier I normally like
you know I wash my face and normally
that dries my skin anyway a little bit
but this week especially I just had to
hurt like my skin was so dry it felt
like and it was probably like somebody's
normal but I'm such a baby but I'm like
I don't like this I want my skin to be
moisturize naturally so we're at the end
of the workday today and I drink about
nine of my 16 glasses so I'll have to
finish what I get home it's just fine
I'm sure and I've made four trips to the
bathroom which is more than I go in a
day usually but this is more in water
than I usually drink - so guess my body
is doing what it's supposed to be doing
my workout on now Nadia says she visited
water well she does this still went to
the gym and I drink water at the gym I
didn't really cut that out as much doing
the best I felt all week I was I was
extremely bloated like all day today I
just noticed that when I get to the half
gallon kind of amount of water I would
feel so uncomfortable with myself in my
body even though I went to the bathroom
fairly often I was still I don't know
I've been feeling quite full this
challenge is shaping up to be a little
bit more difficult than I thought it
would be
so it has officially been seven days
since we started this challenge how did
it go for you
our elf is just the weak if it's because
I've been working out more if it's the
water I my skin has cleared up
and just don't week which is that's
impressive
mind blowing yeah I did not think water
I'm gonna keep trying to drink at least
half a dime just see I should really do
drink any more water that's what I
learned so are you gonna continue to
drink a gallon of water I think I'm
gonna for sure continue to drink a
gallon of water a day just because I'm I
think I'm still used to it I hope I'm
still able to I hope I didn't ruin my
momentum I doubt it I hope not I hope I
didn't ruin your life
[Music]